[Music]
serious drama detective
[Music]
lurking beneath the streets of
Washington DC is a group that seems to
have no affiliation to any of them no
infections in both cities that we've
come across encounters are infrequent
and brutal although they seem to do well
in DC sewer system they can sometimes be
seen scavenging above-ground
presumably looking for supplies this
group is known by many names like the
unchained sewer people chain gang and
the silent ones but officially in game
that can be seen called the underground
in this video I'll be discussing the
possible origins of the underground
faction based on the information found
both in the division 1 & 2 very little
is known about the underground faction
other than they live as sewer dwellers
only coming up to the surface to gather
supplies they are hostile to everyone
they encounter and perhaps the most
creepy thing about them is that they're
almost completely silent all you can
hear is footsteps and the rattling of
chains the underground are identified by
the all black clothing and bright yellow
flashlights they wear on their heads
given the location that they can be
found and the fact that they don't seem
to make a sound it's not unusual to be
within a couple of meters of them before
you realize they're there there are
certain areas that can be found more
often than not but there is no saying
how many of them are around quite often
you'll come across a single unit to be
quickly ambushed by a group of them
flanking you from behind
underground assault class units run from
the semi-automatics but they also have
Russia type units who are quick and will
either throw knives from distance or
rush into close combat unique to the
underground are the thrower class who
through chemical grenades that are
player damage effect that ignores armor
but probably the most memorable member
of the underground group are the heavies
a hulking behemoth covered in chains
running straight at you will do nothing
else but a chainsaw
within the main story there are just two
missions that actually feature the
underground in somewhere during the
beekeeper Jeff side mission right after
you start talking to Jeff the
underground faction immediately launch
an attack after fighting them back
you're able to proceed and exit the
mission without another word spoken
about this mysterious group that laid
siege to the Capitals last line of
defense again while running through the
Navy Hill transmission side mission the
underground faction can be seen when
exiting the Navy Hill bunker the
underground faction are waiting in both
of these instances no extra information
about this faction is given again it
just shows their activity and aggression
beneath the streets of Washington DC
there is a lot of speculation around
these guys with the majority of people
talking about how they're offshoots of
the outcasts a lot of this comes from
the way that they look the outcasts have
a very loose uniform that was thrown
together after capturing Roosevelt
Island from the captives after spending
months as prisoners as a group that has
established itself underground is easy
to understand the finding clothing etc
could be difficult and given that it
isn't the most clean of environments at
the uniform if you want to call it that
is likely to be in a similar rugged
state other than this and they love for
chemical warfare that's where the
similarity ends
another theory during the rounds is that
they're affiliated with the hunters in
some way not necessarily a part of the
same faction but people who worship them
kind of like hunter groupies when the
hunters first appeared in New York City
no one knew anything about them months
later we still have no idea so naturally
rumors start appearing from behind smoke
wearing masks to strike fear into their
enemies
strong enough to take down the most
hardened of agents and then before
anyone can react they disappear without
a trace this is the sort of thing that
legions are made out of so it wouldn't
be unreasonable to suspect that there's
some sort of following being ganged
desperate times call for desperate
measures this underground following does
seem to have been inspired by them in
some way
they're quiet they can never be heard
talking they wear a lot of dark clothing
to keep them hidden in the dark they
have adopted the use of ambush tactics
and prefer a more brutal close combat
style of fighting I love the idea behind
this one it brings the multiple
speculations around hunters that we've
had in real life over the last couple of
years straight back into the game with
the affected civilians are having the
same sort of discussions who are they
where did they come from now for a
theory a little more in line with the
story as factions have come to power
each doubt parts of the city is the
territory settlements and the JTF were
put under pressure they were unable to
take on more civilians looking for
shelter an effect was struggling to hold
what they already had members of society
who are unable to seek refuge in these
areas took to places they weren't
actively being patrolled by the main
hostile factions one of these places is
under the streets of Washington DC given
the knowledge of the area and their
equipment it's possible that it started
as a group of city workers that had
originally started working down there
who then set up a camp underground to
keep themselves safe from what was going
on above they stay down there because
they simply do not have the numbers to
take on the other factions especially
now with the black tusk on the scene
they've been cut off from everything and
after several months without
communication they're suspicious of
everyone the plan is to wait it out to
live quietly underground away from
everyone else until the surface is safe
again this theory shows the deeper side
to how the public have been affected by
the fall of society and how they'll
cling to anything in hopes to survive it
also paints them in a far less hostile
light they're simply trying to survive
defending themselves only as a way to
protect their underground community but
I'm going to take this theory a little
bit further I'm going to show how the
underground faction is a straight
reference to the side story surrounding
the division they're convinced it's the
way to go
mention without them I have no one so I
guess we're going under however run into
anyone for a few days though friendlies
or not there's a hell of a lot of
tunnels down here so I guess you don't
run into people so much which is a good
thing mostly it's quieter than up top
sure and it's also really boring and
dark and wet we've told each other our
life stories and kind of seems like Lisa
Pender everything there is to say
already you were quiet mostly no maybe
this is just the beginning the beginning
of what though I'm not exactly sure
there dreamily how the other night turns
out wasn't a dream okay I guess this
will sound crazy I know it's gonna sound
crazy but that doesn't mean it actually
is crazy I swear to God I swear on a
Bible and swear on the rain Barrett's
hunting knife anything you want I swear
I saw an alligator down here they'd won
it I mean I heard those rumors for years
yes oh if I was [ __ ] I'm a skeptic I
realized I know
all right heard there's no faking
breathing like a dragon really heavy and
wet and the footsteps in your head of
that tail like a huge bag of wet cement
getting dragged down this hole
sister port so some of the guys have
been saying they spotted people prying
up the manhole covers at night inducted
into the sewers my guys were too far
away to decontaminate and it ain't easy
to run in this gear but they marked the
manhole cover and I've been trying to
patrol the area just in case anything or
anyone pops up as far as I'm concerned
anybody going down there is for sure
infected you don't want to hide when you
got nothing to hide for so people in New
York City were going down there is a
wave to hide from the violence above
ground but also because of the
possibility of an escape from Manhattan
Island and after a period of time they
only got smarter with their hiding and
better protecting their settlements it
wouldn't be unreasonable to expect that
the people of DC had the same ideas but
what we're seeing in DC is the very same
people but six months later isolation
deathly quiet disease lack of natural
light
starvation these are all recipes for a
person to lose oneself the people of the
underground have done what they could to
survive normal people like you and I
that have done things that we would have
never considered as an option for
survival we compared to what society
would consider normal people who were
able to survive the initial outbreak of
the virus and managed to avoid being
captured or killed by hostile factions
that came to power had a new struggle to
contend with starvation under these
terrible circumstances with people
around you dying of hunger
cannibalism seemed like a logical step
to survival a number of recordings
reference the shortage of food and what
people were doing to overcome this
and this was further talked about in
April Kelleher's take on events in the
new or collapse book I hope I never get
this desperate pirate glacis his crazy
Colts down in the tunnels pedaling
around on kayaks they took from sporting
goods stores cannibals next he'll say
they're writing alligators and
performing human sacrifices and if he
did some people would believe him the
shock of the dollar bug has broken a lot
of people on top of this there's this
area that can be found that shows what
looks like some sort of wrapped
sacrificing ritual site behind the table
as a mural this is actually an image of
the author HP Lovecraft with one of his
written creations Cthulhu for anyone not
familiar with his work one of his most
well known stories is rats in the walls
summing it up this is a story of an
American named Ella poor the last
descendants of the dello poor family who
moves to his ancestral estate in England
following the death of his only son in
World War one to the dismay of nearby
residents he restores the estate called
excellent Priory after moving in della
paura news cap frequently hear sounds of
rats scurrying behind the walls upon
investigating further and through the
reoccurring dreams della Pugh learns
that his family maintained an
underground city for centuries where
they're raised generations of human
cattle to supply the taste for human
flesh this really could just be me
clutching at straws here but it's an
interesting reference nonetheless so
there you have it based on the
non-existent information that would be
provided on the underground faction it
is in my opinion that they are simply a
group of civilians that have done what
they could to survive they have set up a
settlement underground away from the
rest of society away from the chaos and
violence happening above-ground
resorting to everything imaginable in
order to survive this has been implied
by a number of recordings in New York
including the sightings of a huge
alligator beneath the streets
I'd usually ask a question here about
what you would do in this sort of
situation but not honesty
none of us could ever know and to be
fair I'd really rather not know how many
of my viewers would that way inclined
thank you very much for watching I hope
you've enjoyed it and I'll catch you in
the next one
Cheers
[Music]
you